I'm doing this
Uhhhhm
We're gonna read an old an old favorite of mine: Ichigo 100%
They just announced that they're making "the Ichigo 100% manga receives a sequel in April"
It's time to catch up
Ichigo 100%--
Oh my God...
It's a love story. It's, it's the beautiful love story
I have ever read in my life. Romeo and Juliet? Ha, excuse me
I didn't have any clue what to film today, so I thought [oh], hey
I didn't- I didn't have any clue what to film today, so I thought "Oh hey"
Why don't I just go [through] the old Manga just for the sake of nostalgia
I'm scared because I feel like this is an awful, God-awful idea of a video
I don't think I've ever seen anyone sink this low
This is PewDiePie 2017 any-- everyone.
Ffffuckin' bad idea
"After crossing the 'Do Not Enter' chain" *breaks into a chuckle*
Can't believe I'm fuckin' reading
*as if constipated* I can't believe I'm fuckin' reading it
Sorry-- "climbing the remaining 18 steps, if you opened the heavy door
the most beautiful view in town-"
I always wonder: Why did the- all the schools keep the roof unlocked?
In anime
EVERYTIME
"A foot?"
Question mark?
Wha-what is about to happen?
This one was my favorite. I always shipped- I always shipped her and the main guy
*high-pitched* Kyaaaaa!
Alright, I don't know wha- I don't know what he's saying
But you know I think he
he shoved his face into that girl's ass somehow
I don't- Can you imagine opening a door
This way
and somehow your face end up in a girl's ass
Oh only in Japan. Only in Japan and now he killed her somehow
"Who is this girl?"
Now I remember why I like this manga
"Did she die?"
This is- this is like for 16 year-olds. I think you have to be 16. Or 14?
I don't know like what's the age on this?
Strawberry panties
Ichigo 100% huh?
He's just going full perv on this girl
*extremely soft* God
The feels
The first time they met, the wind just-
Are- are the skirts that short in Japan? I don't think so
"Whaaaaaaaaa!!" "Kyaaaa!!"
Doing a great job of the voices here
She runs off
"Was it something I did?"
Well it could've been the fact that you shoved your face into her asshole
"She's the one who fell down. I'm the one who's surprised!"
Is he seriously mad about that?
"Anyway, was there a beautiful girl like that at our school?"
"So beautiful standing in the evening sun with her skirt waving"
You literally just checked out her ass
"Ah! It's a killer scene! Getting up the camera has to be in slow motion!"
What is he talking about?
"Wait isn't this just an erotic video? Come to think of it, she was up here"
Oh okay
So she fell down in front of him.
"I wonder what she was doing. Hmm?"
This is actually fun! I didn't expect this to be fun!
"3rd year class 4...Toujyo Aya. Class 4?!"
"This is our class... I have no idea, maybe it's not her notebook"
Wait, so this girl is in your class, but you never notice her until her ass was in your face?
Typical men
"Oh well. I have to find the owner tomorrow. Ha, a beautiful girl wearing strawberry panties?"
"Right!"
"What would you call it an angel from...heaven?"
She truly is
"That scene where I saw the girl turning is more beautiful than any other movie I've seen"
"Manaka's being crazy again. But if Manaka is this excited, she must have been a really beautiful girl"
Manaka
That was his name. I remember now!
It's all coming back to me
"Yeah... The only girls he talks about are from movies anyway... 8 rate movies"
What does that mean?
"Hey, Manaka.you picked the girls notebook, right?
What's her name come on tell us I couldn't care if it was someone on Komiyama
Level but fukusa you're popular with the girls so I don't want to tell you
What do you mean my level? Well, you look like surgery went wrong. You look like a street fighter character ah
Come on. I'm not that popular and right now my mind's only on soccer
Talk in this direction. Yes the fuck
So amazing I'm set to go to either music at high school as a student on the soccer program
Thanks for telling us that that's very useful Manaka didn't you say you were going to izumisaka?
Yeah, hurry up and tell us so you can concentrate on your exam?
We'll help you
Actually it belongs to someone in my class. Do you guys know her her name's Toujyo
Come [show], Hiya
Danny I shipped them so hard okay. I shipped them harder than anything, [Toujyo]
Yeah, I think there was a girl like her. [oh], there is really
Why is it so hard for me to remember girls faces and names because you only see them for their?
Booty will already be
Graduating middle school soon, they're in Middle school. I'm sorry
I don't [think] the owner of this book is the girl with a strawberry panties. That's her. She's like
Superman and clark kent she wears the braids and the glasses what if I'm not doing that voice what you found my math notes
haha
We expect someone else. I was looking for it with yesterday. Thanks, [Manaka]. Yeah, but I'm so relieved you found it, [huh]?
Oh, no, look at me. Sorry. You don't have to help me it has to be a different person
I'm sure I never knew torture was displaying that girl. What about my notes? [oh]? Yeah, your notes. Sorry
I forgot them good job. Good job man what I mean, what what it?
Doesn't matter we don't have math today. I'll
Definitely bring it tomorrow okay, but those notes. Have if you try to look up her skirt to see if it was her
No, I won't look at her panties. Hey, [Manaka]. You didn't look right?
Yeah, I didn't look please you cannot look okay, right, [manaka]
Why am I doing this I don't?
How you see she doesn't want him to see yours ichigo panties my writing is so messy
I don't want anyone to see it. Oh she's talking about her notes
All right, I will look at them. You're being serious right manaka. I'll do that. It's my turn to clean today anyway, Na
No, this is the real subs. Okay. This is not a
It's okay might as well. This is actually pretty heavy come on the bells ringing okay in the end. It was all for nothing
Hey, i've been thinking
Wha--! it's demon! who is a demon guys you want to die? Yeah? He does look fucking weird
I don't know maybe [Manaka] saw Nishino [TSUkasa] from class 2. think about it
How many shiny beautiful girls stars like that could there be at this one school? He may be right Tsukasa is
[dammit] man you speak about her whenever you get the chance shut up. What can I do I like her. But anyway
What about [TSUKasa] it's Possible, TSUKasa?
I don't fucking know
But what does Nishino? Nishino that's the blonde girl's name. [I] remember [now]. I
I don't ship her okay?
He needs to be with Toujyo. How can you not know the most beautiful idol in our school. It's a sin to not
Know what she looks like like a sin, it's [so] [whaley] written that I can't read it ah save me Ookusa
OOkusa? Oh-- I don't fucking know. He's just not interested [in] girls
He just loves
Japanese dick. Sorry stop it you guys are so noisy
Anyway, I also think the strawberry panties girl is TSUka...sa
Let's go see what she looks like Manaka
Of course we'll go, but it's definitely her right her hair was semi long and she was wearing a [third] [year] uniform
Right and if it really is an amazing beauty the first thought is tSUkasa
But you don't even know my favorite girl. What are you gay?
You two perverts... it has nothing to do with like or dislike and
He's just talking about her fucking underwear. I simply want to film the moment that girl's panties went up
It was the filming all right. I remember the guys into filmmaking
He wants to film. He was the film were paid if you're 15 the fuck I mean not panties her skirt just her skirt
Sure, buddy. It doesn't matter if it's the panties or skirt ah
[Manaka] is a big pervert. They're running away from him because he said [that] it's a mistake. This is art
I'm seeking art if you want to talk about being a pervert [komiyama]. Is a much bigger pervert than me
It's a well-known fact
Did you say that I'm a pervert you [are] a pervert always talking about, TSUkasa?
And you only think about girls my feelings are very pure and healthy. I'm not like you who doesn't even know Tsukasa
[-] [gasps], can you swear that you never imagined Tsukasa in her panties?
Only someone who's never been in [love] before would think that way you're only in a one-sided relationship. Don't look down on
One-sided love have you ever thought about a girl so much that you cry on your pillow. Have you?
Hey you
I'm moved by your confession. I'm not doing that voice
I'm moved by your confession. But here in the corridor, please find a more obscure place to confess, okay?
He's not confessing to you. You self-absorbed bitch all right tsu tsu tsu tsu tsu
TSUKKIE!! God. I really hate guys like you
Tusk cut her hair short so cute. [this] hairstyle really suits you thank you for your compliment
Don't worry about this guy, [hahaha]
Tsukkie... I
Sorry, I'm not interested in a guy who looks like a dinosaur
YES!
That's true. I don't I don't like dinosaurs looking guys even--- either (He corrected himself?)
I mean, I don't like guys and you the one thinking about panties every night
Look, I'm wearing strawberry panties today
Don't you ever think about these kind of things again
But you just told him! Actually I want to say something back, but I find myself unable to speak
What is... What is with this girl? hey come to your senses! Class is about to start! Why is everyone wearing..
strawberry panties? the mystery... the drama... the passion...
I really think it's her her hairstyle is different, but I had lifted her skirt
She didn't look like someone
Who would hide it in fact she seemed to mind me a lot and told me directly what she was wearing
Hey even if you are right I can't believe Tsuk-- Tsukasa would wear the same underwear for two days
Yeah, that is pretty gross no I can accept that it's only two days my record was five days
Don't compare yourself with her. Hey, you scums it's the dinosaur. Don't you guys have any sympathy for someone who's just been rejected?
Can you guys ignore me? Just because you've solved a mystery of the strawberry panties forgot this guy was here. Hey come on
I have finally known Tsukasa's beauty I get all embarrassed, just thinking about her. So you finally understand then you confess too
[Epic music]
What!? confess to Tsukasa too! I was rejected because of you hey, Manaka
Confess like me and get rejected too have a taste of the pain I feel yeah that makes sense [that] definitely makes sense
How is that my fault? It's your face's fault
[Laughs a little bit]
Yeah, you just need to confess to her. Hey Ookuzz-- Ookusa. I'm not sure what you were on about
But you want Tsukasa's panties on tape right tell her the bared bone truth
If she's not even your girlfriend why would she let you? That's a good good point. That's true
baka (idiot)
Tsukasa has never fallen for a confession. She's the toughest of the tough
Even I was rejected, but there are no rumors of her dating you never know unless you try
You're right
Then I'll have to take that bull by its horns if I succeed I'll be the boyfriend of our year's greatest idol
Okay, I'll do it for my ambition. This make no fucking sense. [I] hope you get rejected
[I] won't get rejected, but how will I find the time to think of a confession?
I'm a busy third year still if I'm going to confess anyway. I hope it goes well yesterday
I was only thinking of strawberry
Panties girl Toay [its] Nishino tSUkasa. What am I doing if I had a video camera?
My first shot would definitely be that girl in the sunset. "Please don't look at it~!!"
she might have said that but her writing is so neat why would she say to not look at it because of the
Content? I'm not interested in Toujyo Aya.
Yes you are! YES. YOU. ARE.
But you might have written about a guy she likes. I'm sorry, Aya. it's packed full of notes
I might be able to copy a few... this is..
What is it?! What is it!? what is it!!?
I need to know!
Okay, next morning
Morning. Good morning, ah manaka
[I] always thought his name reminder a pancake... Pana-- panaka... Pancaka about my math note book today
Manaka! hey Manaka! Why are we on the roof?
Manaka-- Oh my god..
This is so beautiful...
Was so shocked you really are amazing
This is so dramatic. I love it your notes. I read them
What you promised you wouldn't read them yesterday?
I was so hooked on the note novel you wrote Aya. [I] was so amazed you really are a genius
You have more since it's not finished right? and where's the hero [and] the stone golem going?
Have you thought about it yet? You won't laugh right? I'm still dreaming... What??
It's boring though, right, and it's childish. [I] just scribble whatever came to me in my studies
I didn't want to show anyone it's a guilty pleasure
I was just using it as a means to escape my studies when I became tired
This is embarrassing don't say that if you say that then you're also denying me
This is so shit like I don't know why I like this so much. This is fucking ah
Oh, Aya, don't you want to become a novelist you can write amazing stories?
It would be a waste if you don't if you didn't if I told you my dream you would laugh I
Wonder what it would be [like] to not fulfill it because of this I don't even tell my friends
But still I'll tell you I want to make my own movie! Filming your underwear
Sorry, he didn't say that, but when I saw your notes. [I] got really excited
I was only reading the worst, but it how it was like. I was watching a [movie]
you [know] the scene where the legendary mage rises to
races the Golem in the middle of the desert after capturing the image of the golem from the ground looking at
The rest of it has to be captured from above from the point of the flying dragon
Well, can you picture it?
so beautiful [I]
Came up here after school as well. Were you writing your story of here. I come here at lunchtime
[I] might as well. Enjoy the sun if it if there's no wind if only you had drop your notes earlier
Why because we would have been [able] to talk about this earlier! Manuka, are you producing anything
Semen.  nothing I didn't have a video camera [if] I pass my high school exam they [promise] that they buy me one [I]?
[laugh]
Which high school are you going to go to Aya? my first preference is Oumi academy. That's a girl only high school
Can't you go to a co-ed one like Izumisaka!?
Guess the level is too low right and I can't even get into that school without a miracle
eh heh heh
Eee?
Damn, so I won't be able to read the next part of the novel
I want to know how the love story in the protagonists, end. There's the girl with the same Target
That's the main character or the prince is known to [be] more beautiful than anyone who willhe choose?
well, I don't watch romantic movies so I can't imagine it [ah]
Speaking of romance since you're here. I'll ask you Aya, how do you successfully confess to a girl?
YES!
good question
This this is so sudden. I don't
Oh, it's not [that] I'm not confessing to you Aya. wow so nice so smooth
I'm not confessing to you. You already a bitch uh
Do you know Nishino TSUkasa from the class 2?  I have a situation and after confess to her?
I don't really know why you don't know why oh
Look, how sad she get. I guess
Tsukasa is very pretty yeah, so pretty that whenever our eyes crossed like my body turns to stone if there are similar monsters
Then how about confessing as you're doing sports
What?? a guy who just well at sport is really attractive right and if you do sports, then you'll be nice less nervous
I'm joking
That's great. No. It's not. Aya you think of it on another level. Uwa.. huh.. wait
I'll be waiting for the next part of your novel. oh my God. it's not Gonna end. Well what?
Look, I said she is confession set up you already know how you're going to confess. You've been working hard
[how] is [that] like a thing you work hard on anyway? Yeah, I'm confident, too
I'm going to get rejected anyway the confession method is a bit anyway
I'm so nervous look forward to it the impact is going to be amazing [HMM], manaka
Are you looking forward to the girl or just a mess that of confession thing? Yeah? That's a good question
I don't know. I told you I'm so nervous right now if that guy wants to date
He'll have to wait another 10 years [it] seems [about] right then [he] [can] shoot porn as well
Yeah, should I ask Aya for a movie script next? you know Toujyo Aya right the girl with the black rimmed glasses
She fell down and spilled water all over herself. She's the bane of sport clothes. What does that mean?
If she was cute and clumsy I wouldn't care but it's like a pumpkin is clumsy I can't stand her wow
So mean what the fuck Aya isn't a pumpkin
Huh, why are you taking her side? That's right stand up for her
Aya isn't ugly if you took her if she took off her glasses and cut her hair she could be beautiful, too
How do you know that?
What is this are you interested in that pumpkin a person isn't all about their outer appearance
[don't] talk behind her back if you don't even know her wait if she took off her [glasses]. She really could be
But it oh my God. I remember this I
Remember this why did he call her to the bars? [I'm] not sure I didn't hear that much. It doesn't matter
I'm going to shoot Manaka's rejection with this state-of-the-art camera
Kamiyama man you are evil. This is why no girls like you or even even is watching?
That is that Manaka. Okay? He's coming
Ni ni ni ni ni. Nishino, tSUkasa
This is where it begins
Let's go Manaka Junpei!
HUEEEE
with my intense pull up and
I will move Tsukasa's ice cold heart [what] the hell is he doing?
Manaka you have no sense
I like you Nishino Tsukasa! Let's go out!10 anime confessions of all time. She laughs
Okay, if it's you it's okay
Wait did she actually said yes?? and that's chapter one of Ichigo 100%
[wow], wow. This is a good idea. Leave a like spoken out enjoy
Let me know you didn't I'm sorry okay?
A lot of stuff happens, okay, I think it's good
Maybe I don't know if I still like it today
But I don't know I don't know I don't know I don't know what I'm doing guess. It's a bonus video
Take it for what it is
brofist